[Music]
hello and welcome to the session on
DevOps infrastructure setup here we will
see how you can automate your
infrastructure creation management
support and event monitoring the DevOps
approach to software delivery and
development calls for very close
collaboration between development and
operations teams in order to achieve
short faster release cycles that can get
new applications and new features to
your end customers quickly and reliably
the core requirement for DevOps project
is for the programmers and your QA
engineers to have on-demand access to
your development and test beds that
closely mirror the latest production
environment by doing this a truly
production ready code can be created and
verified at various stages of
development and testing it's this
infrastructure on-demand requirement
that holds back many organizations from
adopting the DevOps model for most
organizations their traditional IT
infrastructure was built for stability
and predictability and not for the type
of daily responsiveness that is required
by DevOps let us look at what
infrastructure on-demand is your data
centers should be designed in such a way
that the underlying hardware and
software can respond dynamically to
changing levels of demand in more
fundamental and efficient ways you
should be able to dynamically leverage
pooled IT resources provide flexible IT
capacity and enable the allocation of
resources in line with demand from your
business processes how do you achieve
infrastructure on demand there are
solutions like cloud-based
infrastructure provisioning on demand
where just by clicking a few buttons you
can create a virtual machine of whatever
capacity whatever size you need we also
have various tools in the category
called infrastructure as code where if
you were to provision a hardware and if
you were to provision a server and set
it up and install various software's on
it instead of writing scripts you can
now write entire code that will not only
set up your hard
we're but also install various softwares
on it and do all the necessary
configurations on it
your cloud-based infrastructure
provisioning include service management
asset management of your infrastructure
virtualization and consolidation
information infrastructure energy
efficiency security of your assets and
resilience let's look at service
management as part of cloud
infrastructure this type of special
facility or functionality is provided to
the cloud IT services by various cloud
service providers the facility would
include visibility automation and
control to deliver first-class IT
services through successful cloud
service management and monitoring cloud
providers can use service quality to
differentiate themselves effective cloud
service management also helps lower the
risk of frequent outages that can
jeopardize security systems using these
tools also supports a greater
operational efficiency
helping cloud providers minimize cost
and maximize profit margin however
achieving these goals can be difficult
in a complex virtual delivery
environment where visibility and control
are limited next let's take a look at
asset management so as an organization
with hundreds of resources you are
accountable for not only their
whereabouts but also their maintenance
and accountability paper-based
spreadsheets are simply not robust
enough to track the items you purchase
operate maintain and store having
real-time tracking capabilities to make
faster and accurate business decisions
is essential during before and after a
response assets can be anything your
organization owns from print materials
to guns to vehicles to IT equipment to
temporary shelters any piece of
inventory that is checked out or stored
requires precise management including
real-time location and chain-of-custody
tracking for each and every asset with
the cloud-based asset management system
thousands of data points can be
collected and analyzed from virtually
anywhere any
time in the field tracking assets is all
about knowing where all of your stuff is
at all times
with all the items that you charge with
managing vital assets can easily go
missing fail to receive the proper
maintenance or even be omitted from
reports if they are not tracked in real
time not only can you virtually track
all of your assets but you can attach
documents to ensure a Pio an invoice a
warranty or any other paper document
never goes missing for that piece of
inventory again let's take a look at
what virtualization is in a cloud
infrastructure in computing
virtualization means creating a virtual
version of a device or resource like a
server a storage device a network or
even an operating system with a
framework divides the resource into one
or more execution environments even
something as simple as partitioning a
hard drive is considered virtualization
because you take one hard drive and
partition it to create two separate hard
drives devices applications and human
users are able to interact with virtual
resources as if they were single logical
resources with this the assets or the
property which is involved in providing
the cloud services are actually getting
managed they are getting managed in such
a way so that their value gets maximized
let's look at how hardware and
information can be managed and stored in
a cloud infrastructure cloud computing
brings natural economies of scale the
practicalities of cloud computing mean
high utilization and smoothing of the
inevitable peaks and troughs in your
workload your workloads will share
server infrastructure with other
organizations computing needs this
allows the cloud computing provider to
optimize the hardware needs of its data
centers which means lower cost for you
cloud computing uses less electricity
when you run your own data center your
servers won't be fully utilized unless
yours is a very unusual organization
idle servers waste energy so a cloud
service provider can charge you less for
used then you're spending in your own
data center when you run your own
servers you need to buy more hardware
than you need in case of failure in
extreme cases you need to duplicate
everything having spare hardware lying
idle you know just in case is an
expensive way to maximize uptime typical
clouds have several locations for their
data centers and they mirror your data
and applications across at least two of
them that is a less expensive way of
doing it and another way to enjoy the
clouds economies of scale thus providing
you with the necessary resilience of
course security is a very important
aspect of cloud infrastructure the cloud
infrastructure is responsible for risk
management and customizing governance
risk management refers to risks involved
in services which are being provided by
cloud service provider customization of
governance implies that features of the
governing body or admin body can be
changed but these are completely
dependent on service providers cloud
security provides multiple levels of
control within the network
infrastructure in order to provide
continuity and protection of cloud-based
assets like websites and web
applications whether it is in a public
or private cloud businesses need to
balance the DDoS protection high
availability data security and
regulatory compliance in their cloud
security provider established CDNs have
added security protocol within their
networks to protect sensitive
information and transactions transport
layer security TLS the successor to
secure socket layer SSL safeguards
information to prevent third parties
from eavesdropping or tampering with the
message infrastructure as code is
managing your operations environment in
the same way you manage your
applications or other code for general
releases rather than manually making
configuration changes or using few
scripts to make infrastructure
adjustments the infrastructure is
managed using the same rules and
structures that govern code development
especially when new server instances are
spun up
the concept of infrastructure as code is
similar to programming scripts which are
used to automate important IT processes
however scripts are primarily used to
automate a series of static steps that
must be repeated numerous times across
multiple servers instead of scripts IAC
uses a high-level or descriptive
language to code more versatile and
adaptive provisioning and deployment
processes the IAC process closely
resembles formal software design
practices in which developers carefully
control code versions test code
interations and limits deployment until
the software is proven and approved for
production using code to provision and
deploy servers and applications is
particularly interesting to a software
developer rather than relying on a
system administrator to provision and
manage the operation aspects of a devops
environment a developer can write an IAC
process to provision and deploy a new
application for quality assurance or
even experimental deployment we have
various tools available that support
infrastructure as code tools like puppet
chef ansible and salt puppet is designed
to manage the configuration of unix-like
and microsoft windows systems
declaratively the user describes system
resources and the respective state
either using puppets declarative
language or Ruby DSL and it's stored in
files called puppet manifests puppet
discovers the information via a utility
called factor and compiles the puppet
manifests into a system specific catalog
containing resources and resource
dependency which is then in turn applied
against the target system chef is both
the name of the company as well as the
name of a configuration management tool
the user writes recipes that describe
how shift managers serve our
applications and utilities like apache
HTTP server mysql and even hadoop and
how they are to be configured these
recipes describe a series of resource
that should be in a particular state
packages that should be installed
services that should be running or any
files that should be written ansible is
an open source automation engine that
automates software provisioning
configuration management and application
deployment there is a single controlling
machine which is where orchestration
begins nodes are managed by the
controlling machine over SSH and the
controlling machine describes the
location of nodes through its inventory
salt is an open source configuration
management software and remote execution
engine supporting the infrastructures
code approach to deployment and cloud
management it originated from the need
for very high speed data collection and
execution in the system administration
environment hey once become an expert in
cloud computing then subscribe to
simpler Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turner up and get
certified in cloud computing click here